when you hear about different people
making their claims about 911 you hear
that say you know jet fuel don't doesn't
melt uh steel beams and i'm sure you've
seen the clips on youtube where
different guys are like yes it does and
i don't know if you've seen people
reacting to
what many say jet fuel uh 1500 degree
fahrenheit steel melts at 2 500 but then
they show that steel does lose strength
at around 600 is what they say yeah
what's your argument to that let's get
into this because the official narrative
says in both the twin towers and
building seven uh that the steel in the
case of building seven expanded in the
case of the twin towers uh
weakened
uh and and that they built a whole
narrative based on that and certainly
steel weakens at 1200 degrees fahrenheit
loses half of its strength it can begin
to sag
we don't
we don't challenge that but what we have
in both cases
is the evidence of molten iron
and that is incredible it is found by
the us geological survey in all of their
dust samples previously molten iron
microspheres about the diameter of a
human hair
four tons of them by extrapolation well
they don't tell us where those came from
where did they come from this is
incredible iron doesn't melt until 2 800
degrees so yes steel weakens earlier
but nist denies the evidence of extreme
temperatures which are available
where published in a metallurgical
examination in the appendix sea by fema
in 2002 before
nist took over the investigation and
threw out that metallurgical examination
why well what did it say
it said
that there's a hot temperature corrosion
attack on the steel
liquid molten iron invading the grain
boundaries of the steel well wait what's
liquid molten iron
we haven't used iron in our skyscrapers
for 100 years where does it come from
well molten iron is the byproduct of
thermite thermite is an incendiary used
by the military to cut through steel
like a hot knife through butter
so maybe we're getting somewhere right
we have a plausible
the only plausible
explanation of how the liquid molten
iron got there and there are hundreds of
of uh well there's there's dozens of
studies showing and witnesses of liquid
molten iron including the world trade
center structural engineer himself
leslie robertson who said a river of
steel flowing
wow
well
we've got to get to the bottom of the
of of all of these witnesses we show
dozens of them on our on our uh
documentary 911 explosive evidence
experts speak out
that's on the website too and it's free
on youtube everybody can see it there
are uh agencies fema in addition to fema
there's uh the osha and and bechtel and
others and giuliani in his commission
report testimony
he
talks about temperatures exceeding 2 800
degrees
well fires don't produce those
temperatures there may be 500 or 1400
degrees nist claims without any evidence
1800 degree fires
but that's a thousand degrees short of
what the evidence shows
in the world trade center uh
molten iron the first responders say
flowing like lava that down the channel
rails you know they're underneath uh
it's an incredible uh
uh
number of witnesses of this molten iron
in fact it's pouring out of the south
tower minutes prior to its collapse this
is clearly uh exceeding temperatures of
2500 degrees we can tell by the color of
molten metals what their
temperature is
so
how do we get those temperatures
this is what's revealed uh also
in the study
by niels harrett and eight other
international scientists
which is peer-reviewed and published in
the bentham open chemical physics
journal because they studied seven
independently collected samples of the
powdered concrete
and we have
the documentation in there
of unignited
thermite
in fact nanothermite
they have these red gray chips they
thought they were paint
it's amazing they they said well uh
let's do some tests on them they're
attracted by a magnet they have a high
iron content one of the key ingredients
of thermite so they do x-ray energy
dispersive spectroscopy xcds and they
find
iron and aluminum the two ingredients of
thermite wow this is getting interesting
they do
they zoom in 50 000 times with an
electron microscope
and what do they find
nano sized particles of iron oxide and
aluminum powder
a thousand times smaller in the diameter
of a human hair
these are
uh
very carefully documented they're in a
matrix a bed of oxygen silica carbon
organic material which is used in tnt to
expand rapidly
knocking things over that's what
high-energy explosives do
but
they
they they find that then this is a
a
very sophisticated form of incendiary of
thermite which is called nanothermite it
was peer-reviewed in lost by los alamos
lawrence livermore lab and guess what
happens when they put these chips
in a differential scanning calorimeter a
heater
they ignite
at 758 degrees fahrenheit producing
just like the by the way the the
peer-reviewed literature that came
before so this this is clearly the super
thermite but what do these chips produce
when they ignite
molten iron microspheres
with the same chemical signature as the
molten iron microspheres that
the usgs finds an rj lead group an
environmental consulting firm and all
the world trade center dust
so you see we know
where
these molten iron microspheres came from
that the usgs couldn't and wouldn't or
wouldn't explain
that we know that this is a self
corroborating repeatable set of
experimental data
that shows us what brought down the
towers when you consider it in concert
with all the rest of the evidence that
we have yet to cover so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]